um so this one was about the most
difficult i could give you to do
this one
is an easy one
because i'm not going
like that with my body leaning i'm
actually doing that with my body
that and what did i say i like teaching
here see there's a shape there that's
got the same thing i like teaching in
this place see
we start putting our body in the same
positions
and we start piling up what we can do
the same
so we get here when we get here and then
we bring it here
so now i'm at this angle and he's at
that angle
what is the contradiction of what i've
been saying
yes
so with the teachers say
point the little finger put your nose
and go into the person don't they you
know we'll tell them that
at my level i'm here
because i
do that
but what i do is i just move the hips
like my outer dory from one foot to the
other
but you don't see it
what you see is me going down but what
i'm really if i go down it'll block me
if i go like that with a little
shift of
hips
so i've got
this i've got that
sorry
that'll be nice and nailed on the old
mic
um
so i want you to do xiaomi
nikki oh but at your level
if i'm
up to show dan
i do it like that
and i face them
watch my hands how much work they're
having to do
he's standing still i'm turning my hand
i'm doing that and i'm putting him on
there
no guy in the street is ever going to
wait that long for you to do all that
if i use the
theory oh please go past
i've got that if the hand was up
that way it would be cut the gosh
that way it would be
roku it can be lots of techniques so i'm
excited about do one move and get lots
of things
oh please go fast i have to just twist
it for the cutter guys
so i get that i get this bigger tyre but
he doesn't get his hand all the way down
like the kaitenagi to stop himself he's
actually comfortable it was a bit of a
shock but in that time i quickly put it
to there from there to there
there
see i'm still not moving him he's still
happy what
thinking there's nothing happening now i
just apply the nicky up
and that's the that's the shot that's
the bit where you win
i don't i've
told you this before
i've done it to a guy who went to punch
me in a checklist tobacco restaurant
a bar
he went and punched me and i just
went out away done that
nick yo he passed out next morning he's
got his arm in a sling he goes
hey i want a word with you and i go i
don't know trouble no he said i just
want to know what the hell did you do
marvelous
so nicki oh
in a surprise attack works but it's only
a
quick piece over and downwards you're
going to do that
the full
thing
and that's
but you will be at different stages
depending on your level
the lower the level the more you have to
work
mechanically
but then
find out where your tension is